Studying up on early modern English taught
me how an old letter end up printing
press made us start
mispronouncing a Scottish name
in my search for the true
sound of Shakespeare.
Long hours at the library paid off with
way too many amazing subplots to squeeze
into one video before I tuck them into
my notebook and turn out the lights.
Let me share one story I really loved
about a different kind of English.
Thanks to a lung linguistic pass.
There are more varieties of English and
the British isles in in the rest of the
English speaking world.
At the extremes,
these actually behave
like different languages.
We meet one of those
extremes in the far north.
Scott's not Gaelic,
not standard English with a
truly Scottish bear. Scots,
it's the local lowlands way of
saying Scottish, just as their word.
Inglis evolved to ingles.
Scotus shortened to Scott's.
Consider your company carefully before
you weigh in on calling it in lead or a
dialect. It's a bit of a
charged issue, but either way,
sculpts has its own separate history.
The northern edges of Middle English
gained a strong foothold in the lowlands
pushing Scottish Gaelic to the highlands.
The Scots lead emerged and evolved
into its own sub branch of England,
complete with Scott's dialects and even
a literary form with quirks of its own
quirks like Yo.
This early English letter was a form of
Ge used for a few sounds including the
glide Yang Yi and the recipe sound
at the end of its own name. Yo,
this letter didn't last down.
South Claxton's printing press
would print g and you like this,
but when Scotland got it's printing Press
York was still alive and Yi you and in
the name McKinney. Kenny. Hi.
See, back then printing
involved wouldn't sticks.
Metal pieces forms to people to ink
in press. It was a whole process.
These weren't the days of holding down
a key on your phone until you got a
little pop up to choose.
The right special character type was
literally metal pieces stored in a type
case, so you'd print with the type you
had on hand and you would keep around just
enough to print. That's spelled
the beginning of the end for y'all.
The story goes that when the presses
in Scotland didn't have the type,
the middle piece for yoga and
there wouldn't type cases,
they just grabbed the letter zed
instead close enough. Right? I've,
especially since they're handwritten
forms look so similar at the time.
It's not that confusing either.
After all,
whether you called this
letter zed or is it modern?
Scott still doesn't use
it much for the sound,
but some words became so well known in
print that eventually people base their
pronunciation on that printed spelling,
reading a XA sound back into a word
that never had it in the first place.
This shortcut didn't impact
thing in or dramatic,
nor the earlier spelling of the I yet,
but it is how mckenny
turned into Mackenzie.
This cork is a great example of how
language varieties can preserve a little
bits of history,
even events as specific as hauling a
printing press into town and picking
letters out of a box. All
right, and I'll follow up.
I'll get back to work on the next full
tail. The one you patrons voted for.
Consider becoming a patron yourself.
If you want to help me spend more time
making videos, I deeply appreciate it.
Most importantly,
stick around and subscribe for lead.